[Musique]
il se passe quelque chose entre un
fantôme
quelque chose de louche
mon enquête venait à peine de commencer
et cette banque cachée d'un assassin
[Applaudissements]
nous notre travail c'est mettre des
amendes à 130 francs tu fais n'importe
quoi tu pourrais te faire tuer espèce
des trucs vraiment bizarre
ce que tu fais là
il y a quelqu'un qui essaie de me faire
tomber ok je sais tout ce qui se passe
dans cette ville
tu craches pas là
si non mais pas dans la GTI tu fais quoi
là pourquoi tu veux pas faire la police
la police c'est moi toi aussi tu as des
crises
va falloir vous calmer la place tout est
en train de m'échapper vous êtes
complètement folle
sauvage
[Musique]
c'est la signature d'un tueur en série
je vous encourage à faire le bon choix
[Musique]